théo est étudiant en communication il
recherche une alternance le stylo à
éviter c'est bien par écrit marne c'est
bizarre aussi te dire que ça attirera
l'attention je trouve moi pour mettre
toutes les chances de son côté il
participe à un coaching personnalisé
pour perfectionner ses candidatures
c'est très intéressant en fait d'avoir
un avis de quelqu'un qui ne vous connaît
pas et qui va pouvoir juger de
votre performance de manière
extrêmement objective en fait souvent
les personnes que je vois sont trop
modestes ils mettent pas en avant leurs
qualités c'est incroyable
c'est vraiment incroyable
on va toutes les qualités après son
coaching chaque participant peut faire
le tour de la quarantaine de stands qui
composent le forum de l'apprentissage
organisé par la cfdt
pour cette cinquième édition le syndicat
a choisi strap
notre objectif était vraiment de mettre
en relation les jeunes des quartiers
alors pas forcément défavorisés mais où
il y avait une certaine discrimination
et un fort taux de chômage pour leur
ouvrir notre réseau à
et leur faire voir un emploi un stage
une alternance c'est pas bon qu'on
envoie un cv en ligne par exemple on
n'aura pas de réponse
en fait on est devant la personne tout
de suite et à prendre des notes cv du
coup certains si puissante année
l'événement en partenariat avec pôle
emploi on voit plusieurs acteurs de
l'emploi des entreprises qui recrutent
mais aussi des associations comme
aprodema elle propose de découvrir les
métiers de l'agroéquipement on estime
qu'ils nous manquent à peu près 6000
emplois qui restent non pourvus chaque
année général non par exemple un jeune
gay informations dans les formations aux
équipements à la fin il entre deux et
trois offres minimum d'emploi pour ce
délit bien sûr on lors de la dernière
édition du forum à nanterre 250
personnes avaient trouvé un emploi